all right ben first of all this is
you're a 90-day newbie you've been
thrown into this world
how has it been so far how would you
describe your experience you know i
expected it to be uh pretty brutal you
know people are going to have very
strong opinions but i'm kind of made for
that so i'm good you know i don't mind
it it also you know serves my purpose of
having a platform for the things that i
care about like the michigan lupus
foundation and raising awareness for
people with lupus there's good and bad
in everything but i choose just to like
really focus on the good okay well let's
clear some things up because so many
rumors are circulating
first of all how did you get cast on the
show did you apply or did tlc reach out
to you
um
so there's a video going around where
i'm talking about something completely
different one of my fitness uh pictures
got put in a magazine and so i was
approached by another show not tlc but
just some kind of random dating show and
i was like
no that's no good you know it just i it
just doesn't you know serve my purpose
and it i got a reputation of kids and
it's just you know no so i said no to
that one but then not long after that
maybe a couple months after that i'm
getting involved with this person online
and it's becoming real and i'm just like
man this would make a perfect story that
i would love to share for the entire
world and so i emailed tlc thank you for
clearing that up because i was confused
to myself it seems like a really simple
answer and i think anyone that actually
saw that video could get it if they
watch the whole thing but people have
got about a five-second attention span
and so they don't get to the you know
thing
well you say you joined the show for
a larger purpose
but there are some people who think that
you're here to pursue your modeling and
acting career what do you say to those
fans so my acting career consists of
playing tarzan
like eight years ago
at a little family you know community
theater with my kids we all you know
joined together and i was just supposed
to be like one of you know the jungle
you know animals
and they accidentally cast me as tarzan
you know wasn't supposed to happen like
that so that is my whole acting career
that's it i'm not really wanting to
pursue that again uh the community
theater may want me back but i'm
definitely not heading to hollywood
anytime soon as far as my modeling
career like
in detroit it's very very limited like i
work maybe
maybe four or five times a year
and i've got a an agency you know that
gets me work every once in a while but i
actually you know not too long ago just
called them up and shut it down and just
said i'm really not interested in doing
that anymore i don't want to spend my
time like that it doesn't interest me uh
it doesn't want you know it's not
something i want to pursue so
uh that's not really part of the plan
oh
there are a lot of
us who have thought or either still
think that
something is off with mahogany either
some people think she's a paid actor
some people think your storyline is
scripted
you have people even debating if her
accent is real or not online
no no no not
it's not sweet okay is it true
what's the truth though ben who
what's going on with this woman
so you you know uh the pete rose
principle right
no uh
okay so major league baseball has a no
tolerance policy about anyone betting on
the games
and it's a lifetime ban even though pete
rose a lot of people think he deserves
to be in the hall of fame you know he's
never gonna be there because he got
caught betting and it's just it's a part
of baseball you just can't have and it's
the same thing with tlc it's the same
thing with reality tv the the minute
they hire an actor
it's over no one's going to watch who
wants to watch that you know it just
doesn't make any sense so tlc has a
choice between finding someone in love
uh and there's thousands of applicants
or hiring a random person which one do
you think they're gonna do to protect
you know their name and make sure that
the viewers have the most authentic
experience it just doesn't make any
sense
and i don't know how that's even a rumor
that they hired us like how would they
find us in a phone book like i'm not an
actor i think people are just trying to
make sense of the fact that mahogany is
real because for so long we were
thinking then you're tripping she's not
real and then she walks into the
restaurant
did producers have to talk her into
actually meeting you there no absolutely
not um so
what happened was
i'm talking to someone online and we get
very very comfortable with that context
and that's the context she's comfortable
in
and then all of a sudden i'm coming to
the country and she wants me there
but then she's scared
and it becomes very very real to her so
it's just an inner conflict with her as
to whether she wants to continue the
relationship because an online
relationship is easy you know you can
just turn off your phone when you're
done and turn it on when you're
interested and and a real relationship
in person is a completely different
thing well for me it wasn't
for me my heart was just as
as full uh full of joy and love and and
affection for her online or in real life
now for her it was a different thing
so she just had this real inner conflict
and when she decided to make it real
it was a huge decision huge decision for
her to do that obviously she's a lot
younger than i am she's got parents uh
in play and and her parents are very
very worried for her
they don't know me at all
and
you know coming in with a whole uh
production crew and and lights and
cameras like that can be really scary
and then just like an older man coming
in without really knowing me and first
that can be really scary so i totally
understand her hesitancy
for sure for sure i want to get into her
age but before we get into that mahogany
is a beautiful girl right but it's very
clear that her photos were heavily
filtered
what are your thoughts on
that because it could say a lot about
where she stands in her confidence you
know and and whether or not she knows
who she truly is yet she's not trying to
in my opinion deceive anyone she's
having a fun time if she's a young girl
at 20 years old and she finds an app
that kind of morphs your face you know
so we've all done snapchat filters and
had a good time with it you know she
just posted it and and so that she never
thought the entire world would be
looking at that and judging her for it
you know she was just having fun so i
don't
have any problem with it i think it's
just you know very
you know i don't know
it's fine it doesn't it doesn't really
matter well as a young woman you know
who is on social media as well i have i
have a different perspective but i feel
like that's a conversation i should have
with her and not you because you know
you can only speak so much for her
yeah and my opinion is it's just like it
wasn't to me deceptive at all i i didn't
really find it like that i could tell
that the pictures were were doctored a
little bit you know and i didn't really
take it seriously um to me it was much
more of a spiritual connection i wanted
to know her heart and that's what we
were focused on the entire relationship
do you want to tour for my home yeah i'd
love to see it
i thought you were 24.
well let's get into these alarming lies
the lies that mahogany
you know
they were coming back to back so one you
found out that her apartment was not
really her apartment it was clearly an
airbnb
and then she lied to you about her age
she's not 24 she's 22.
what do you make of those lies and
how how can you still want to be with
someone who has lied to you that much
so you have to kind of know the whole
history and there's never enough time
you know in a 10 minute segment on tv to
really get into it so i'm here to tell
you i went back through all the texts to
see
how many times she lied about her age
and
for some reason i did a lot of assuming
and
and i didn't even ask her about it it
was just the very first day that we met
she said that she was 23 when she was 21
and it was within the first maybe 10
minutes of us even meeting like hello i
am a
you know 23 year old peruvian girl and
um so it was and i wasn't even
interested in pursuing her at that time
it was just literally the first five
minutes and that's the last time she
even mentioned it
so
i don't feel like she was trying to
deceive me for months and months and
months we shouldn't even talk about it
and then i looked at her birthday when
she when i thought she turned 24
and sure enough i never said happy 24th
i never said hey you're 24 now like we
never even mentioned the age it just it
was just assumed i just assumed she
turned 24 but she didn't like
you know keep reiterating reiterating
the lie it was a one-time lie and it's
something that i would tell my kids if
you meet a strange older man online
don't tell them your social security
number don't tell them your address
don't tell them your age if you do tell
them your age change it up because you
don't know if they're going to be a
stalker or a crazy person so not a
problem to me at all the house thing
um
i don't know i kind of get it like
if you've got a guy you're trying to
impress you know and you're
and she and i'm coming over to her
country
um
maybe you don't want to show him exactly
where you live you know and maybe you
don't want to be like here's my home
address hope you come back and stalk me
someday like i don't know it's a safety
thing but it's also just you know i want
to impress this guy and to me i have to
decide whether that is a red flag or or
if i understand it there's a lot of
things maybe that we all try to hide
about ourselves for the first impression
uh so not a big deal to me i just
you know wonder why she didn't say i
don't want to give you my home address
then let's meet here because that does
speak to where she is in her life as a
22 year old woman how she can sit here
and say oh this is my bedroom okay this
is my bedroom like this is my bathroom
um this is my bathroom el bano
that doesn't make you feel
funny
well she was living there
you know she was actually living there
and she lived there for a couple months
because her bedroom was empty i was like
is this a 24 year old woman's bedroom
i'm sure that most of her stuff was at
her parents house like i said i look at
everything on the positive side and
probably too much so right because i
mean because everything isn't always
good isn't always positive i feel like
everything is always working for our
good but you have to make a reality for
what it is to actually learn the lessons
you need to learn
you get what i'm saying absolutely
don't gloss over the red flags then
you know i have a tendency to do that if
if there is a major
thing that i think is uh you know
something we can't get past
um then that's one thing but if
someone's just trying to you know
have me show up and and this is where
they're living for a couple months you
know i just i wasn't asking a whole lot
of questions so
you know that's on me for not pursuing
it harder and and more thoroughly
okay
well let's get back to her age this is a
fan question issa wants to know why is
24 okay and not 22. two-year age
difference
yeah and that really did have more to do
with my kids i don't you know have a 24
year old uh but i do have a 22 year old
so it just i thought if she's older than
my kids it just
psychologically you know is not that big
of a deal and and even that isn't that
big of a deal to me
as far as the age of my kids because i
don't look at it that way she's a
completely separate adult
and it doesn't matter to me if um
you know my kids of that age it's just
something that kind of caught me off
guard and i had to think about it for a
minute but this has become so much more
than age and so much more
than than
you know
our differences
uh the things that we've been really
focusing on are
our commonalities
and and so those so far outweigh our
differences and she is so mature and
wise and and intelligent that i haven't
really felt that difference
oc wants to know
would you be comfortable with your 22
year old daughter dating a 50 year old
man
right and you know that's probably the
number one question i've gotten on my
social media
uh and and they feel like that's the
ringer like oh man if he can answer
i thought i said oh see that's a good
question yeah absolutely and i am very
interested in maughani i told her from
the very beginning i will not pursue a
relationship with you
if your father is against it your mom
and dad both have to be on board but
your dad is your first protector
and if he says no
then it's dead in the water there's no
one that loves mahogany more
in this world than her dad and so all
the viewers out there that are so
concerned for her and think that i'm you
know a predator and coming after a young
girl trust me when i say that dad cares
more about the situation than anyone
from the outside
and so if he sees
that i am very very healthy which i find
myself the exception and i'm sure that's
probably rationalizing what i'm doing so
i'll give you that bringing it back to
your daughter if you're 22 year old
daughter
i would hope that the gentleman the 50
year old would have the same exact rules
that i have
and that is he has to go through me
and i interview him and i look at him
and i look at his health
i look at his viability i look at his
context i look at his background i look
at his intentions and you know would
there be a chance that i'd ever let them
date i don't know it would really have
to depend on the individual but i'd look
at every individual differently but i
would hope that he would give me veto
power
because that's exactly what i'm giving
ma ogani's dad so
so if a 50 year old came up to me and
said i want to date your daughter i'd
say let's sit down let's talk about it
and let's uh continue this relationship
for several weeks and let me you know
discover who you are and find your
intentions and if you are not going to
um
like live with my daughter and if you're
going to go through me and do everything
correctly and go through all the right
channels
and respect the family
then i'm willing to listen at least
okay how does your daughter feel about
you a mahogany knowing that they are the
same age
is she a waiter
she yeah she's she's very aware
maughani
cares almost as much about my daughter
as she cares about me how did she react
to knowing her age or learning about
that my dad is dating someone my own age
how did she react
um well my daughter and i have such a
strong relationship and such a good
relationship
that she trusts me she knows that i'm
not going to be
not careful she knows that i'm not going
to
put someone in her life that's not good
for her and she knows that i'm very
serious when it comes to my
relationships i grew up in a fringe
religion of a mainstream baptist
denomination
that was very much like a cult we
learned about your childhood experience
you grew up in a very strict religious
home
do you think that that had that has
anything to do with um you being naive
when it comes to dating and being so
i guess optimistic about people and
overlooking red flags do you think that
has anything to do with it
there probably is um i have been in
therapy for a year and a half i went
through a dating time in my life that i
just was not happy with it was just not
good i
and i was just frustrated i was like i
never want to you know go through this
again and so i started going into
therapy and she said you can't date for
a year and and i ended up not dating for
a year and a half and i really took it
very seriously um because yeah there's a
lot of layers here and when you're in
the kind of
context i was in very cultural religious
my my first marriage just was so
disastrous that i felt like
am i just trying to start all over you
know and and dating someone so young you
know is me trying to you know just
capture those years back
and i really don't think so i would be
willing to date someone who is in their
50s i really and i have before and i've
dated my last serious relationship with
someone who was 39. it's not about the
age to me i met someone whose heart
and whose soul is just so beautiful and
someone that i could just like connect
with in such a different level i just
didn't want to let that go and i wanted
to pursue it and so i pursued it
unfortunately i pursued it for millions
of people to watch and and that has been
very very difficult
[Music]